JENNY BROWN: Find out how
the life science community
uses Google Cloud Platform
to organize the world's
genomic information while
also making it securely
accessible and useful.
On this episode,
we'll see how it's
done through a quick
demo where you'll
use Google's implementation
of the htsget protocol
and SAMtools to create a
project using public data.
Genomics is the study of the
genome and its environments.
Today, DNA sequencing
advances have
made biology a data-rich
field for the first time.
And the volume of
genomic data available
is growing exponentially.
Cloud genomics offers
petabyte-scale genomic data
processing and analysis.
Now, let's see how this works.
To get started with
this lab, you'll
have to enable the genomics API.
We run some commands in Cloud
Shell to run the htsget server
and attach it to a local Docker
container network named "test."
We then use sequence
alignment map tools
to view statistics about a
small range on chromosome 11
on a public genome.
In just a few
seconds, the SAMtools
have processed over
1,500 reads that
were streamed from a file
in Google Cloud Storage.
Highly complex searches
that previously
could have taken
minutes are now taking
as little as four seconds.
This kind of speed
and scalability
is accelerating breakthroughs
in understanding the causes
and subtypes of conditions in
ways that can advance diagnosis
and treatment as never before.
Qwiklabs is an online,
hands-on lab library
available 24 hours a
day, seven days a week,
with more than 150 labs on
every cloud topic, from intro
to expert level.
Each lab helps you learn a
new skill in about 30 minutes,
using Google Cloud.
Take the Google
Genomics Quickstart
lab, the same lab we
just went through today,
and practice working with Google
Genomics API for yourself.
When you're ready, use
this link to take the lab.
And when you're ready
to sign up for GCP,
use this link to apply a
$300 credit to your account.
We want to hear from you.
Every week, we'll be answering
a question from our viewers,
so let us know what's on your
mind in the comments below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]